(man) the sharks are back
looking for the best products
and Businesses
America has to offer.
If they hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
you need me very badly.
I know how to Sue people.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You seem a little desperate
at this point.
I'm not
the least bit desperate.
You haven't shut up
since you o--made your offer.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
I want your help
and I want your money.
No, no, no.
You're so full of crap.
(men, chanting) Kiss, kiss,
kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss.
I feel the fire.
(laughs)
Oh! (laughs)
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,
filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate Empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-filled city
of Manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made,
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas mavericks.
♪♪♪
I'm Dallas Robinson...
and I'm Mike buonomo...
(both) and we're
from salt lake city, utah.
We first met in college,
and we just kinda clicked.
Some Ideas just percolate up.
We've created something that
creates a chemistry
between two people
that's absolutely Amazing.
Yeah?
Yeah, I think that's right.
We grew up with
a very strong moral background,
and we always walk, uh...
(chuckles)
a little bit of a fine line
with our product,
but we feel like we've found
a way to come together
with Our moral backgrounds
and still promote
this awesome product.
So Everybody's been
super supportive
about our venture,
uh, especially our wives.
They've gotten jobs
to help support our--
what do you--
our endeavor.
Yeah, our endeavors.
(chuckles)
It would be huge
to get an investment
with one of the sharks.
We've gone as far
as we can by ourselves.
We have to have somebody to help
us get through the next level.
♪♪♪
Hello, sharks.
I'm Dallas Robinson...
and I'm Mike buonomo,
and our company is kisstixx.
We're seeking
a $200,000 investment
for 20% of our company.
Now just a few years ago
when I was a high school senior,
I focused on two things--
having fun in the sun
and trying to get
the cute girls to kiss me.
Now I quickly found out
that these activities
don't always mix Well.
While playing in the sun,
my lips would get dry
and chapped,
and at that point,
no one wanted to kiss me,
so I tried every lip balm
out on the market,
and the only thing worse
than kissing dry, chapped lips
are chapped lips that taste
like Cherry cough syrup.
It's disgusting, so I knew
there had to be a better way
to soften up my lips and ramp up
my game with the ladies,
and that's why
I created kisstixx.
Kisstixx is
a high-quality Lip balm
that comes packaged
in two compatible flavors--
one for you
and one for your partner.
When you kiss,
these amazing flavors combine,
creating
a chemistry reaction
That's bursting
with Flavors and aroma.
Now we have several delicious
combinations here for you,
including strawberry daiquiri
and piÑa colada,
so when you kiss, you get
miami vice, just like the drink.
(chuckles)
We have peaches and cream,
raspberry and lemonade,
and our best seller,
fire and ice,
where one heats up
while the other cools down,
creating
a fun tingling sensation
that you will never forget.
Now fortunately for you guys,
we brought with us
our fully functional
kissing Booth,
so a f--a kissing Booth always
features a beautiful lady,
So, Barbara, we were wondering
if you could come down
and help us on this one?
No. Hold it right there.
Who's gonna kiss me?
Kevin!
(men laugh)
Come on down!
Come on--come on down
and help us out. (chuckles)
I love it.
Like Mike said,
this is our best seller,
fire and ice, okay?
Wait. Wait.
Did you invite him?
Absolutely.
Absolutely. Get down here.
Yeah, absolutely. (laughs)
I've been waiting, Barbara.
Barbara, you're already
hot enough...
All right.
So for you, we got some ice
to cool you down...
(chuckling)
Yeah.
So there's some ice for ya.
You can go ahead
and just put it on.
All right.
This is the fire.
Since you're--
fire.
(men laughing)
We figured, since you're,
you know, a little hotheaded,
we got the fire for ya,
right?
Absolutely.
Barbara, are you really
gonna kiss Kevin?
No, I hope not. (laughs)
Here you go.
There's the fire for ya.
We'll find out real soon.
All right.
(chuckles)
Wow. Tingly.
Feels Good.
Mm. Ooh.
Listen, Barbara,
if I turn to stone,
I'm gonna be pretty unhappy.
(all laughing)
(men, chanting)
Kiss, kiss, kiss...
and then kiss
kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss...
to mix the flavors.
Barbara, let's go.
(laughs)
Come on, sweetie.
Oh, no.
Just a little Peck.
(chants)
Go, go, go, go, go.
You have to do it
just to make sure it works.
I'm backing you up here.
Come on. Let's try it out.
(Robert) Smooch, baby!
(laughs) Don't grab her.
Don't... (laughs)
I'm ready, Baby.
Kevin, no fondling.
You have to commit to it.
Don't get your dentures
locked up, guys.
(laughs)
I feel the fire.
(Barbara and Robert laugh)
(mark) Oh, lord.
I'm gonna get ill.
Oh!
(laughs)
I didn't get there.
No, you have to hold it
for just a second...
all right.
Yeah? You gotta--
so you can get
the full effect.
(laughs)
Ohh!
Let's hold it, sweetie.
Ready?
(laughing)
hold it. You gotta hold it.
A little longer.
Ohh!
(laughing)
Yes! (laughing) Yes.
Oh, my God. Yes.
(laughs)
Tasty. Very tasty.
Ohh.
(high-pitched Voice)
That's so disgusting.
Why did I have
to see that?
(laughs)
That's so disgusting.
Did you feel anything?
It worked.
(Barbara) Oh, god.
You definitely get
a, uh, change in flavor.
So the question is,
who's feeling the chemistry
and ready to invest in us?
W--so do you have
any sales of this stuff?
Wait, wait, wait.
Just for the record,
I want to say... (chuckles)
You know how
when you kiss someone,
it can change your feeling?
This didn't change a thing.
(men chuckling)
it confirmed--
it confirmed it all.
But you'll always
remember it, so...
Oh, god.
(chuckles) Yeah, so will
the whole world.
(chuckles)
(Robert) Yeah.
How does it work?
We had in our minds,
we wanted it to Tingle,
we wanted it to change flavors,
so a team of chemists came up
with our formulas.
They're better
than anything out there.
They actually work, and they do
the Tingle sensation.
What about revenue?
What about sales?
We've been doing this
just barely a year last month...
(daymond) Here we go.
And we actually--
(Robert and mark chuckle)
We hit a milestone for us,
which is $80,000 in Sales.
Total for the year, right?
Um...
what do you think a business
that does $80,000 in sales
is worth?
Sales and a half.
Okay, so that would get you
kinda into the $100,000,
$120,000 range...
sure.
And you're telling me
your business is worth
a million dollars,
because you want me
to give you $200,000 for 20%.
Right.
What's the problem?
This.
It's our new Vendor paperwork
That's setting us up with one of
the largest drugstore chains
in the United States, walgreens,
so...
Dallas, can I see it?
Have they placed an order?
Is it a test or--
can I see it?
Is it a test
or is it in every store?
What they want to do is
roll us out in 7,500 stores
for
Valentine's day promotion.
$540,000 is what they're gonna
order in product,
see how it goes.
What's it cost you
to make one of these?
Yeah.
Depending on volume,
between 86 cents and $1.
And that's for one of them
or for--
that's for the package
that you see right there.
Everything all together.
The whole package of two?
Mm-hmm.
And what are you gonna sell them
to--to your big retailer?
We're wholesaling 'em
right now for $3 a unit,
and then they're retailing 'em
at about $5.99.
So how much will you make
on that order?
We'll make $337,000.
Dallas, how did you get
walgreens?
Well, I went out
and tried to find people
who knew people
at walgreens.
We went to them, and they
brokered us in to walgreens.
Mike, tell me
about the other $80,000,
not the walgreens.
Who bought that $80,000?
We sell on our web site,
but we're in over 100
retail locations right now.
Um, we actually just got
approved for--
in 485 associated food stores
that we started distributing to
two weeks ago.
Where do you see it going?
We've got several ideas
for other mix-and-match
Kissing products
that we want to bring out
after the fact.
Like what?
The next thing that we have
is called kiss mists,
and it's, like, a breath spray,
so it's the same kind of idea.
Oh, that's cool.
We want to roll out gum
as well,
so you can do
the kisstixx Gum.
That's actually very cool.
(Barbara chuckles)
Uh, it could just be
the aftereffect of kissing
Kevin O'Leary...
(laughs)
(Kevin and Dallas chuckle)
My gut is saying
big-time No. I'm out.
It's a bad memory.
(mark and daymond laugh)
You're telling me
it's worth a million bucks,
and I can't get there.
That's what's really
holding me back.
I'm certainly impressed
with what you've done.
Now I didn't turn to stone
when I kissed Barbara, but...
(mark chuckles)
What's interesting is
that the two people that kissed
aren't doing the deal,
so I don't know
what that says...
but I'm out.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out.
Dallas and Mike have
three more chances
to make a deal.
What's interesting is
that the two people that kissed
aren't doing the deal,
so I don't know what that says.
I'm on the fence.
Push me one way or another.
You've got two
of the hardest working guys
you'll ever meet up here.
We won't let you down
with this.
We went and knocked doors
and did summer sales
and just to get enough money
to make this our dream
and keep this going.
So how would you use
the 200k?
Well, we'd use $167,000
of that for the walgreens order.
Um, that's gonna--
okay, so for inventory.
Yeah, for inventory,
and then the rest of it,
we want to get
more distribution with it,
and we want
to get our name out there.
I like what you're doing,
but I think
your Valuation's too high.
I think you can be fun,
hip, innovative,
and kinda a little bit edgy,
which is cool,
so I'm willing
to give you the $200,000
for the--for 40%,
but the other good news is,
as you grow, I'll be there
to help you finance
all that other inventory
without asking you
for more equity.
Mark has made you
a better offer than I would.
I'm out.
I love to compete and win
against mark Cuban.
(mark and daymond laugh)
So does Everybody.
Yeah, but I usually do.
Um...
compete But not win.
(chuckles)
It's a better offer
than I would have made.
I'm out.
You need to make
a decision.
Time to decide.
Well, we would love
to accept your offer.
We'd love to work
with you.
I know you would,
and I would, too.
Awesome.
Thanks, guys.
(chuckles)
Thank you.
(speaks indistinctly)
Thanks so much.
Thanks. (chuckles)
Congratulations, guys.
You guys are doing
a great job, man. You both are.
Thanks.
(Dallas) Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Kevin, was there a Tingle
after you kissed Barbara?
Yeah, you get
a little burst of flavor.
Did you get
a little excited?
Well, it was more than that.
(laughs)
Oh, no. (laughs)
I had a--I had
a burning sensation.
(sharks laugh)
I can't believe
we got a deal with mark, um,
but even more Unbelievable
is that we got
Barbara and Kevin to kiss,
so... (chuckles)
it might not work out
between them,
but it sure worked out
for us, so...
(chuckles) Worked for us.
Sweet.
♪♪♪
Last season
we watched Kimberly Nelson
strike a deal
with Barbara Corcoran with
her homemade cake business,
Daisy cakes.
Thank you.
What an experience being
on "Shark Tank" Has been.
Oh, my goodness. Amazing!
Prior to "Shark tank,"
we sold 2,000 cakes in a year,
and now we're averaging
over $100,000 in sales a month,
and because of
this huge increase in orders,
I was forced to find
a larger bakery.
I've moved from my small kitchen
with four ovens
to a much larger bakery
with Big walk-in ovens,
and the production has
increased dramatically,
from being able to bake
eight cakes at a time
to about 160 cakes.
One of my favorite things
is that I've been able to ship
my cakes all over the country,
even all the way up
in the north pole.
I write little notes
to people on the boxes,
so that, um, they know that
some Southern Love
is Coming their way.
Oh, my gosh.
This looks Beautiful.
Working With Barbara is
absolutely amazing.
She is so smart and creative.
Most of all,
she's extremely well-connected.
Since I was a little girl,
I have been baking.
This is my life's dream,
and now thanks to "Shark tank"
And thanks to Barbara,
it has all come to fruition.
♪♪♪
Next up are
Stephanie and Daniel rensing
with tools to make life easier
for the home Baker.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Stephanie...
and I'm
her husband Daniel...
and our business is
the smart Baker.
We are seeking $75,000
for a 25% stake in our company.
Home baking has never been
more popular than it is today.
More and more people are
getting back into the kitchen
and making things from scratch
to help them save money.
Our goal at the smart Baker
is to make
those bakers' lives easier.
Since most recipes call
for an amount much too high
for just two people,
I'm always left on my own
to scale recipes down
and convert odd measurements.
I'd always wind up
with a baking disaster
that no one wanted to eat.
(mouths word)
(mark and Kevin laugh)
my husband and I created a way
to solve this problem
and have all this information
at a Baker's fingertips
when they need it.
And where better to put this
than on their apron?
What's unique is that
it's printed upside down,
so you can read it
while you're wearing it.
Within two weeks of creating
the cheat sheet apron
and putting it online,
we quickly went from selling
a few a week to over 50 a day
right out of our garage.
We've also designed a line
of Parchment paper that
comes in precut, flat sheets
that are made to fit
the most common Size
baking Pans.
Plus, we've added
unique lift tabs that
put us ahead
of our competitors.
Oh, good idea.
Our newest hot item is our line
of cupcake and treat Towers.
Unlike other disposable towers
made of cardboard,
the smart Baker's cupcake
and treat tower is reusable
and made of
washable, durable P.V.C.,
eliminating the need
to constantly replace
after every use.
With your help, we can make
everyone a smart Baker,
and we'd like you
to be one, too.
Thank you, Stephanie.
Here you go.
Look at that.
Thank you.
Okay, so this is very cute.
Let's talk about what matters--
money.
Do you have any sales?
We do. Uh, overall we've had
about $72,000 in sales.
In the past three months alone,
we've had over $34,000.
What do you think you'll do
for the rest of this year?
We're hoping to end the year
out at about $140,000.
We hope to net about
$100,000.
Great Margin. That's how
you start a small business.
So are you living off this,
or this is a Hobby?
Right now, for me,
this is a full-time job.
Last year, I was
an ELEMENTARY art teacher,
but I actually just found out
yesterday that I lost my job...
Oh.
Wow.
That sucks.
So smart Baker will now be
full-time for me,
and I'm gonna need
to make it work.
One door closes,
another one opens, right?
Are you selling
everything on a web site,
going to trade shows?
How are you actually
selling the product?
Currently We're selling
them online,
through mail-order catalog
with the aprons.
We've done, uh,
some trade shows.
What's your best seller?
Currently our best seller
is the cupcake tower.
We've done about $40,000
in Sales since October.
What does it sell for?
Retail, $59.99 to $64.95.
I think what puts
our cupcake towers Apart
is that it could be
for a big, grand event
like a wedding,
but using our modular design,
you could take off
a tier or two,
and you have
a smaller structure,
good for smaller parties.
(Robert) Stephanie,
do you mind me asking
how long
you've been married?
Eight months,
but together ten years.
So you went out
for ten years
and have only been married
for eight months?
That's his fault.
(all laugh)
Did--did you ever date
anybody else?
Nope.
High school sweethearts.
No. Yeah.
Wow. No kidding?
The reason I asked is you have
such a great relationship,
the way you finish
each other's sentences...
(chuckles)
Without arguing.
What is it with the syrup
all the time?
Robert gets so sappy
on everything. My Goodness.
Let's say you had the time
and the help to focus
just on getting more sales.
What would you do?
The first thing I would do
is the trade shows.
When people see the product,
they fall in love with it.
Yeah.
You know what, guys?
I-I like what you're doing,
but I think
I'm such an internet geek
I'd probably have a hard time
on the retail side.
You have a strategy there,
and I might be the guy
to hold you back,
so for that reason,
I'm gonna say I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Now I buy
your premise that,
the economy being soft,
casual dining dollars are down.
I'm just wondering, though,
how do you scale this business?
You're sort of on the cusp of
being a Hobby versus a business.
Your valuation is not crazy.
You're asking for a value
of $300,000
on something
that might make $100,000.
Trouble is, you gotta eat,
literally...
correct.
So you gotta pay yourself
most of the profits,
so for me, as an investment,
it's--it's very marginal.
Not enough meat on the bone
to invest in it.
I'm out.
I know I can be
like Kevin sometimes,
where I think I know
everything about everything...
(chuckles)
But you don't.
You're not like me.
But in this case...
(chuckles) I actually don't know
that much about the baking
and--and cooking business.
I will definitely be a customer.
I just can't add value to you.
Okay.
I'm out.
Three sharks are out.
Daymond and Barbara
are Stephanie and Daniel's
last chances to make a deal.
Are you making an offer?
I'm not sure.
So, Stephanie and Daniel,
I want to offer you
the $75,000
for 40% of your company.
Is that the only offer?
It's the only offer
I heard.
The only offer you heard.
It's a hard one for me.
I could argue either side of it.
Do you have any debt?
(Stephanie and Daniel)
No. No debt.
You know, I bought
a business in the tank here
named Daisy Cakes.
She had, for the year,
$3,000 in sales.
Do you know she's been selling
$100,000 worth of cakes a month?
Wow.
That's awesome.
But I made a deal with her
that I was wondering,
perhaps you might consider,
because it gave me
an opportunity
to get the money back out,
if you might pay me a f--
well, he'll call it a royalty.
I'm calling it a return,
a 5% return on what you sell,
and if you'd be willing
to do that,
I was going to make
the exact same offer
the guy who knows nothing
about baking just made,
$75,000 for 40%, but let me
tell you what I do know.
I know distributorship.
I know the baking business.
I know the technology piece
of the food business,
and I know
the marketing business.
And she knows how
to kiss Butt and lie.
(laughs) Oh.
You understand the difference
between the shark
and the Sharkette's offer?
This one comes
with a 5% royalty on top of it.
This one comes with everything
needed to make your business
a huge business quickly,
and let me tell you something,
I could take your sales,
and I could quintuple them
in a month, simply because I've
set up the network to do it,
which was not easy to set up
and very expensive.
This guy doesn't know a darn
thing about the baking business.
You know what?
The only problem about this
is that I don't remember
seeing Barbara
around the thanksgiving table.
She's not family.
She doesn't know what I know,
so she can basically tell
her great resume and say
how much I don't know.
She doesn't have a clue.
So you're in
the baking business?
I might be.
I did fail to tell you
one thing.
The royalty on--
is totally ended
the minute I recoup
the investment.
Tell them anything else
you want to tell them...
I've told them everything.
'cause you--
you seem a little desperate
at this point.
Stephanie...
I'm not
the least bit desperate.
(speaks indistinctly)
You haven't shut up
since you o--made
your offer.
This is why I love the tank.
You have two offers.
What are you gonna do?
I'm gonna counter
Barbara's offer,
see if she is willing to do
$100,000 for the 40%
with the 5% royalty.
I'd have to say no on that.
(mouth full) Wow.
Does your previous offer
still stand?
It's $75,000 for 40%
with the 5% of sales
off the top
until it's repaid,
definitely.
You got a deal.
I think we will take it.
(Barbara) whoo!
There you go.
Yes.
Whoa.
That was so exciting!
(Stephanie and Daniel
laughing)
(laughs)
Mwah!
How about me?
Oh.
He can dip you, too.
No, no. I don't want a kiss.
I just felt left out.
He can dip you. (laughs)
Yes. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Great. The smart Bakers.
Thank you so much.
(Kevin) Ohh.
I'm so excited.
Yeah. (chuckles)
(high-pitched voice) Oh!
(normal voice)
Got what we came for, baby.
What were you doing putting
your nose in that business?
I was gonna license it,
that's all.
License it.
I don't like to lose,
but I'm happy for them.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank is
Lyle schuette
with a household product
he invented for his wife.
Hi. My name is Lyle schuette,
and I'm from Derby, kansas,
and my product
is the heat helper.
I am here today
to ask for $100,000
in exchange for 50% equity
in my product.
The heat helper is
an amazingly simple device.
It saves energy and money,
especially in times
when we need it now,
when the economy is tough.
I came up
with the heat helper
out of pure necessity.
(chuckles)
My wife had injured her back
and during her recovery
asked if there was any way that
I could raise the Dryer up
so when she did laundry
she wouldn't have to bend over
to get the clothes
in and out of the Dryer,
"and while you're at it,
can you heat up
that end of the house?"
now my mother--
she was a very smart woman.
Now I remember back home
on my parents' dairy farm
in wisconsin,
my mother would take
her old panty hose
and stick on the back
of the Dryer.
Why? Because she could catch
the heat and the humidity
that came out of the Dryer,
so during laundry day,
our home was
a lot more comfortable.
Now before I explain
how the heat helper works,
you must first understand
how an ELECTRIC Dryer Works.
An electric Dryer works
by pulling in air
through the back of the unit,
heating that air up.
Then it blows the air out
of your home.
What a waste.
Now what the heat helper does
is take that same amount of Air
that your Dryer uses,
filters it,
and then blowing it
back inside your home.
It pays for itself
in the first year.
I call the Heat helper...
(taps)
Common sense in a box.
(Robert chuckles)
Now Let's do some Business.
(mark, daymond,
and Robert laugh)
first question I have to ask is,
if my wife hurt her back
and I didn't volunteer to do
the laundry for her...
(Barbara laughs)
I'd be black and blue.
How did you get away
with that?
Well, I started
a dirt business,
and I'm normally gone
all day long,
and since my wife, at that time,
was a stay-at-home mom,
it was all right for her
to do that.
She--she cut you
some Slack, huh?
Yes, sir.
Lyle, what's
a dirt business?
I am a Terra firma RELOCATION
distribution Engineer.
(sharks laugh)
(chuckles) in other words,
I move a lot of dirt.
I'm a drainage contractor,
and I sell topsoil and compost.
Lyle, how did your wife
hurt her back?
She fell in a hole of a pond
I was digging on our farm.
(laughs)
I knew it was dirt.
(chuckles)
I knew it.
You didn't do that
on purpose?
I told her to go left.
No, I told her to go left,
and she went right,
and next thing I know,
there she was.
And then you made her do
the laundry.
(laughs)
Oh, god.
Dirt bites again.
So--
did you help her out
of the hole,
or did you build
something?
In the words of my wife,
she never saw
my old Butt move so fast.
Ah! (chuckles)
Have you had any sales?
I've had 680 units sold,
all through the web site.
How much does a unit cost?
$99, and--and we have sold 'em
at Lowe's and at walmart.
And how much can that save me
in my heating bill?
Well, an average family
of four will save
roughly $189 a year.
Lyle, you said you were
in home--Lowe's?
Lyle, what--
yes, we've been in Lowe's
for three years and in Walmart.
How many have you sold
in the last year?
Probably 20.
Why is that?
Why--why did you fall off
so dramatically?
I ended the company
in 2003,
because my dirt business
took off,
where I could not do both.
Lyle, the walmart
and Lowe's deal you had--
was that on a national basis
or just regional?
That was
my local two Lowe's stores
and my local walmart.
Okay.
We had to sell 'em
as a special order item.
They--until I sold--
did you try
to go national?
The response I got
when we did call is,
you need to sell
a certain amount of units,
and once you get
to that point,
They would consider 'em
to put me on the shelf.
So--okay, so that's where
We're getting.
Why do you feel that
the Units didn't sell?
Well, special order items mean
there's a display
at the store,
but you can't pick it up.
That's terrible.
You have to order it
that day...
Deadly. Mm-hmm.
And then he has to come back
in another day or two.
So great presentation, um,
but if Lowe's and those guys
couldn't really sell,
I don't want
to get into a space where
the professionals weren't
able to do it,
so I'm out.
Lyle...
yes, sir?
I love you.
You're the first--
I love you, too, man.
(chuckles)
No, no. Let me tell you why.
(mark, Barbara,
and Robert laugh)
You're the first guy
I've ever met that
made money selling dirt.
I sell manure, sir.
(chuckles)
Hey, if you can sell poo-poo
and make money,
that's fantastic...
yes, sir.
But it's not gonna be
a huge business,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Lyle, you got busy
with your dirt business,
and it kinda sat on the side,
and now you're here
showing it again,
bringing it back to life.
There's something used
and warmed up about it and over
that makes me uncomfortable.
(inhales deeply)
So I'd have to say
I am out.
Well, I never lost interest
in it, Barbara.
But you brought it back
from the dead.
I mean, to me--
it--yeah,
and--and the same unit
we have--I built for my wife
10 or 11 years ago,
we still use.
All the ones that
we have sold,
we haven't had one RETURN
or complaint,
because there's only
one moving part.
Lyle, you saw a need
from your wife,
and you created a product.
Not an investment right now.
(chuckles) I'm out.
Lyle, I gotta tell you,
your heart's in it.
It's a good idea.
It fills a need,
but it's just tough
to write a check to somebody
who's not eating, sleeping,
and breathing the business,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
Yeah.
Thank you, Lyle.
Thank you.
I thank all of you folks.
Have a great day.
All right.
(daymond and Barbara)
Good luck.
You, too, Lyle.
Good luck to you.
All right. Bye-Bye.
(chuckles)
What a great guy.
He is.
Yeah, a very nice guy.
One fun guy.
He should have let us invest
in his dirt business.
(chuckles)
I didn't get a deal today,
and that kinda disappoints me,
but, you know, life's too short.
Get over it, and it's all right.
I'm still coming home, Honey.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank is
Scott Jordan,
who hopes to entice the sharks
with the patent
for his clothing Technology.
Hi.
My name is Scott Jordan.
I'm the founder
and C.E.O. Of tec,
and I'm seeking
a $500,000 investment
in exchange
for 15% of my company.
You see, I'm a gadget guy.
I gotta have my stuff
with me wherever I'm going.
At any given moment,
I've got my cell phone,
my digital camera,
my tablet, my laptop,
and all the gadgets and gizmos
and headsets and batteries
that go along with it.
The list is never-ending.
Technology certainly has
made my life easier,
but it can be a lot
of stuff to carry around,
especially when you travel
as often as I do.
So what if I told you I had
everything on this desk
in the Vest
I'm wearing right now?
Introducing Tec--
technology enabled Clothing.
(clicks and whirs)
(electricity hums)
(whooshes and clicks)
Tec is a patented system
that lets you carry
everything you need,
know where it is,
and access it easily in
Specially designed pockets.
We've engineered our pockets
to fit almost any device,
and these pockets are
layered into clothing
so that there are no bulges
and everything is Balanced.
Many of these hidden pockets
have unique features, like--
check this out--
cleartouch fabric that
allows you to see
and control your device
right through the FABRIC
without ever taking it out.
We've even developed
a patented system
to wire your headphones
right through the lining,
so you no longer have to contend
with this tangled web of wires
every time you have a call
or Want to listen to your music.
I intend to license tec
to every major clothing company,
because I know
that this can become
the next huge ingredient brand,
like gor-tex, velcro,
polartec,
and so many others.
Right now tec is poised
to revolutionize
the clothing industry,
and this is
a billion-dollar opportunity.
All right. I've told you
about my pockets.
Now it's time for you
to reach deep into yours.
Scott, two days ago,
I'm flipping through the back
of "Men's journal" Magazine,
and there was a similar product,
and I thought,
wow, what a great idea.
Yeah.
Is that you?
(chuckles) That is--
it is a great idea,
and--and it is my product.
I formed a retail company
to prove the concept of
technology enabled clothing,
and I've been running
that company
for a-a number of years,
waiting for the patent,
and now that it is issued,
I'm here seeking an investment
in Technology enabled clothing
as a licensing company
to bring this system--
the intellectual property
along with
the registered brand name
and the product know-how--
to other clothing companies.
Tell me about
the retail business,
'cause that proves the concept.
Yes, it does. It's like--
what are the sales
in the retail business?
Well, to date,
it's $5.1 million,
and we're on track to do
$12 million this year.
The retail business--
is that real--
That's not part of this.
(mouths word)
That's not part of it?
No.
Is the idea now
that we're not gonna sell
this retail,
we're simply gonna step back,
take the intellectual property,
the I.P.,
and license it to others?
That--that's exactly right.
I-in terms of the offer
I'm presenting here today,
it's for
the intellectual property
and the brand name,
the bigger idea,
the billion-dollar idea.
Right.
The sharks have discovered
Scott only wants to sell
and not in his lucrative
retail clothing Business.
Scott, you're saying
that the proprietary patent,
which you say you have now...
yes, I do.
Is what you're selling me,
right?
Right.
Why aren't you bundling it
all together?
Why are you being
so greedy and Savage?
'cause I'm like you.
(chuckles) Oh.
(laughs)
What I'd like you
to understand is that
what my other company
has been doing
has been building the brand
of technology enabled clothing
for years.
What is the technology
we are buying?
I see that you can put
the speakers through the Hood.
Now I know Burton--
uh, n-not through the Hood,
but through
the pocketing system, Yeah.
Headphones--
uh, I know Burton has done
this for years,
so what exactly do you have
that's different
from all the other ones
that I know exist?
Well, th-they infringed
on our patent.
Have you ever protected it?
Yes.
And you collected?
Did you win?
Yes.
I've settled with 11
of the largest companies,
including V.F. Corporation,
north face...
Sure.
Ralph Lauren,
Calvin Klein...
okay.
Under Armour, spyder.
Are you getting
an ongoing royalty?
Uh, it's subject
to non--uh,
confidentiality agreements...
but wait a second, though.
And so--
is it getting a royalty stream
from the settlements?
You don't have
to tell me how much.
Uh, yes.
Okay, listen.
And is that part
of your bottom line?
Stop right now.
You need me very badly.
Yes.
I know how to Sue people.
(mark, Barbara, and Scott laugh)
This is going to be wonderful.
I want it all, though.
Why are you just giving me
a taste,
when I want to eat
the whole pie?
But, Kevin, Kevin, hey.
Let's not get--let's--
I don't need you
for the other company.
Kevin. Kevin.
Kevin.
Yes, you do.
Oh. (chuckles)
I just don't.
The problem is,
there's leakage in the deal.
I don't get
any of the good stuff,
just the risky stuff.
No, it--
no, it's not risky.
So, Scott, what exactly is
the property that you own that
you can defend
and have defended?
A garment
with no wires in it
but the capacity
to wire things in it.
Is it a design patent?
Yeah,
design and utility patent.
And it's been issued?
Not only issued,
not only tested in litigation,
but recently reexamined
and passed reexamination.
So basically, the patent
is attributable to the wires?
That's right.
Only the wires?
So they--for example,
this pocket here
has a hole in it
that leads up through here.
That's ridiculous.
That is ridiculous.
That's just common sense.
Wires in, wires out.
That's what's killing
this country,
that we get dumbass patents
that people
then turn around and Sue,
when it's just
common sense stuff.
Yes, I love this country.
It's ridiculous.
But, uh--
you're being un-American.
Think--think about--
think about this.
I understand
as a businessman
exactly what you're saying,
especially as an EX-lawyer
who hated dealing
with Lawyers so much
I stopped practicing law.
Running a wire
through a piece of clothing?
I'm telling you, mark.
I mean, I-I--
that's a patent?
Are you kidding me?!
who cares? Retail value.
No, you're crazy. No, no, no,
no. You're so full of crap.
(daymond) Scott, the cases
you have defended have been
when--argument's sake,
let's say one of my designers--
and I have 30 of 'em--
decide to wire something, a Hood
or something else like that.
It goes out.
We don't even know you exist
and have that patent.
You hit us. We say, "instead
of paying the attorney bills,
"Give him $50,000 to go away
'cause we don't have time
for this," and that's it.
And that's the reason why you've
got to defend all of those--
and that is horrible,
horrible, horrible, horrible.
I love it!
Why do you say that?
That is what this country
was formed on...
you're a lawyer.
You're gonna say that.
Coming up with a unique idea
and defending it.
Scott, just to be really clear,
you came up
with a fantastic idea.
You patented that idea.
You went out and built
a business on your idea
that'll do
$12 million this year,
$24 million next year...
if not more.
And now you don't want
to sell us any of that business.
You just wanna take the idea
and sell us the patent of it.
Yes, I do.
My other business only has
a very insignificant part
of a much larger market.
No, because
your other business
could end up being
the billion-dollar business
that we have nothing in.
Did you start it
just to cap off at $12 million?
You're gonna grow
that business.
Um...
and you're gonna have
the first right
to this technology
and not have to pay us.
That's all negotiable. Okay?
I mean...
so...
I'm here to negotiate.
Would you sell me 15%
of that business
for $500,000?
You've gotta be kidding me.
(laughs)
Wait. Wait.
Yeah, but that is--
that's insane.
♪♪♪
All sharks are in,
and Scott has one offer
on the table from Robert--
$500,000 for 15% of
the patent to the technology
and his retail clothing
business.
But Scott is only interested
in selling the patent
and not including his lucrative
retail clothing business.
Would you sell me 15%
of that business
for $500,000?
You've gotta be kidding me.
(laughs)
Wait. Wait.
Yeah, but that is--
that's insane.
Why is that insane?
Because We're gonna make t--
how much money are you gonna
make on that $12 million?
$2.1 million.
You just called him insane
for offering you
a half a million dollars.
For a company that's making
$2 million? Yes.
So then why are you here?
Honestly,
I want your connections.
I want your expertise,
I want your help,
and I want your money.
(Kevin) Look...
may I just stop you there?
I have to ask you something.
Do you have a business partner?
Yes.
They must be a saint...
(laughs)
Because you strike me like
you'd be one pain in the neck--
he's a lawyer.
What do you expect?
Yeah, but beyond that.
You're tough.
You know who the partner is?
(Robert) who?
My wife.
Oh, god.
Is she a lawyer, too?
Yes.
(laughs)
(Barbara) and you know what?
Shocking!
Scott, Scott, just to be clear,
I'm out.
I understand.
Scott, okay, so we're talking
about $1.2 million free cash?
Yeah.
What's a clothing company
trading at these days?
Let's call it five times?
No.
Why?
Inter--internet Clo--'cause
we're direct to consumer.
We're internet
clothing company.
What's it worth?
$30 Million.
$30 million?
$30 Million on--
who's insane now?
'cause it's growing
at 100% a year.
It has intellectual property.
That's where it's unique.
It's online.
It's building a brand.
A lifestyle brand.
It--it's not--first of all,
the intellectual property
is built about running a wire
the clothing.
A rivet, a wire, velcro.
It doesn't matter
what it is.
It does matter because
wireless is what's next.
Wires will not go away
with battery power,
and--and for the time being,
for music.
People will always prefer
to listen to music
with wire Headsets.
Sound Quality's better.
You don't have to worry
about pairing issues.
I-I don't agree.
I'll put low power bluetooth
into the shoulder.
Let it distribute
to all the other devices
and to the headphones.
I'd kick your ass.
So I'm out.
You were out
from the moment you sat down,
so I--you know,
you're no loss.
What is your problem?
Why would you say a comment
like that to mark?
You called me insane.
No, I--your valuations
were insane.
I think it's an insult
that you wouldn't offer us
part of the bigger picture.
I'm out.
Three sharks are out,
and Scott has one offer
on the table from Robert.
(Kevin) You know,
they asked a scorpion
why it would kill something
that's floating across the pond.
'cause it's its nature.
You're a lawyer. It's
your nature to be like this.
I'm okay with it.
Mark brings up a great point
about wireless.
You gotta admit that.
It hasn't happened today.
It's coming,
and technology changes,
and there will be very low-cost
wireless headphones.
It'll erode your share.
In the meantime,
you're doing a great job
building this business.
Now Robert made you an offer.
He said, bundle them together
and he'll give you 500k for 15%.
I'll go in with him
on that deal and go 50/50,
or I'll offer you
a million bucks.
If he wants to come in with me,
we'll double it
for 30%.
I gave you $500,000 for 15%.
I don't need O'Leary on that.
Would you consider that?
Fine, then I'll make the--
I'll make the same offer.
You can choose between us.
I'll make you the same offer
'cause I think
combining them together
in the clothing industry,
with the risk of wireless
taking some share away
in the next 36 months--
500k for 15%.
Scott, is--is there a premise
under which
you're gonna entertain and offer
in the real business?
Well, I-I have a call
that I need to make.
You know who was
on my advisory board?
Steve Wozniak,
the cofounder of apple.
I-I need to talk
with Steve Wozniak.
Tell woz I said "Hi," too.
I will.
Would you like to say hi,
Kevin?
Sure. I sold him
a ton of software.
I was their education business
for years.
You shouldn't be able
to take nonsense like that
and turn it into a patent,
and then fill up
the legal system,
and then create unlimited
uncertainty for companies.
It's wrong.
It's absolutely wrong.
I agree with you, mark.
I love him.
Steve, thanks.
Oh, my God. It's very good
to hear from you.
Here--here's the deal.
I got two offers on the table.
Uh, both from, uh, Kevin
and, un, Robert.
They're the same amount--
$500,000 for 15%,
which is what I asked for,
but they're insisting that I
include my other retail company.
I'm--I'm sorry. That's just
too much for this kind of offer.
I-I mean, I don't think
this Offer's good enough
for, you know, giving up,
you know, um,
you know,
what you've got going already.
What he's doing right now is,
he's trying to figure out,
is he serious about selling
the REAL business or not?
If I believe he will, maybe I'll
make him a real offer.
All right, come on back.
Ready or...
I-I don't wanna...
we were just talking bad
about you, but it's okay.
(laughs)
You can interrupt.
Um, you know, Steve says hi.
(grunts)
He doesn't know you. Sorry.
(daymond and Barbara) Ohh!
(laughs)
No, I'm kidding. I...
first, before I relay
Steve's comments, um,
would anyone else like
to, you know, reconsider?
Why don't you tell us
what woz said?
Woz, you know,
just thought that it was
an AWFULLY low offer for such
a well-established business.
Did woz agree, though,
that the only logical Play
was that it's one business,
not two businesses?
Um, you--we didn't talk
about that specifically,
although woz knew
what I was pitching
because I've discussed this
with him.
Your answer to $500,000 for 15%,
I'm taking it, is no.
Um, I-I wanted you give you
another opportunity
and, uh, you know...
to bid against himself?
Well, I mean, to--to rethink.
Why don't you counter?
I mean, to rethink the logic
of one m--
you know, Scott, the way
it works in the tank is,
we make an offer, you counter.
All right,
then let me be clear.
Kevin, you're out.
You're out.
I don't--I don't need you.
Wow.
You had $1 MILLION
sitting here.
Will your wife represent me in
suing you for wasting my time?
(laughs)
Because that's all you're doing
right now.
You didn't come to make a deal.
I didn't waste your time.
Don't waste ours.
(speaks indistinctly)
Hey, Scott. You know what?
Seriously, what the hell?
You point at me
and you tell me I'm out?
Uh... Bye-Bye.
(Robert) Show a little more
respect.
Ugh! That was exhausting.
That was painful.
As my mother always said,
the fish stinks from the head.
Why are we still
talking about it?
I went in looking for a deal.
I truly did.
But unfortunately,
the valuation that they put
on my other company...
combined Was just insulting.
I had no other choice.
I had to walk.